Professor Amy
Hungerford: Okay.
I'll go ahead and start,
just 'cause I am not sure how
many people will end up being
here.
So, as promised,
today I will tell you a little
bit about the exam,
and I'll show you some
questions from a past year so
that you can see what they're
like.
We rewrite the exam every year.
Even makeup exams are all
different, so I have a lot of
these in my files.
The exam is two-and-a-half
hours in a three-hour slot.
We have two rooms,
'cause we have a big class.
They have given us this room
and 102, so you can come to
either room for the event
Friday, May 9,2:00pm to 5:00pm.
It has three parts.
The first part is
identifications,
and that's small things from
any of the novels.
That could be a character.
It could be a place name.
It could be even a couple of
words, a quotation,
and you have to give the author
and title that it comes from,
of the book that it comes from,
and tell us what it is and a
couple of sentences about its
significance,
so why that thing is important.
Passages will be little
chunks of text from a novel.
Again, you'll have to know
author and title,
and then you will have to do an
interpretation of the passage.
And then you have to say in a
couple of sentences how that
passage as you have interpreted
it is important to the book as a
whole.
Oh, and you have to say the
context of the passage.
Now this might differ.
I'll give you a couple of
examples.
This'll be different.
It might be a matter of saying
where in the plot it occurs or
who, which character,
is speaking,
what's going on in the scene
from which it's pulled,
some sort of relevant context
so that we know that you
understand where the thing comes
from.
So you have fifteen minutes to
do each of those.
The essay is 40% of the
final grade.
You have a half an hour,
and--I'll show you--I have a
special way of doing these
essays.
Usually, they're big,
general questions.
A good way to review for that
is to look at the old essay
questions, the essay topics.
You'll find a lot of clues
there about themes that unite
all the works on the syllabus,
so that can be a good way of
studying.
In each of these sections
you will get to choose.
So, in the IDs usually I give
nine, and you get to choose six.
In the passages,
I aim for seven and you choose
four.
In the essays I always give
three and you choose one.
Within the essays you can
choose between two lists of
books to use to answer your
questions.
You get to choose three of four
on each of those two lists,
and I'll explain a little bit
why I do that when I show you
one.
The one restriction on the
essay is that you may only write
about one novel you've written a
long paper on,
so only one of the three novels
that you choose to write about
for the essay question can be
one that you wrote about in a
paper.
So your TF who will be grading
the exam will know what you
wrote on, so just observe that
guideline.
It's written in the directions
of the exam.
Now, so,
let me show you now what these
look like.
First of all,
I'm going to give you a couple
IDs and we'll play a little
game.
Who can identify this?
So, "sea horses."
Yes.
No, I'm not going to call on
you, Sarah.
That's not fair.
Only if they're all washed up.
Can anyone except Sarah
identify this?
Okay, Sarah, go ahead.
Student:
That's in
Housekeeping.
Professor Amy
Hungerford: That's right.
Okay.
Did that seem hard?
Judging by the paucity of
answers it was.
Yes, that's exactly what you
need to say.
You need to say Marilynne
Robinson,
Housekeeping, and
you'd have to explain that she
always wanted to look at this
little drawing that her husband
made for her.
Let me think of another one.
The dancing bear.
More of you know that.
Yes, Helen.Student:
Blood
Meridian.Professor
Amy Hungerford:
Okay.
Yes. Very good.
So you-- That's the end of
Blood Meridian.
You would have to say that
it's at the very end in order to
get full credit for that ID,
so you need to know that.
Let me think of another one.
Oh, Lane as a name, Lane.
Yes.Student:
Franny and Zooey by
J.
D.
Salinger.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Yes,
absolutely, and you might want
to say what he represents.
So, what would he represent?
If you were going to give a
sentence about what he
represents, what would you say,
why he's
important?Student:
He represents kind of the
ideas of education,
and that education isn't always
a good thing.Professor
Amy Hungerford:
Yes-- Student:
And that he's not
necessarily educated at all in
the way that other characters
think is
important.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Yes,
that's true,
and he's pretentious.
So, he's much more interested
in his possibilities for
publication and how well he's
done in his course than he is in
the wisdom that Franny and Zooey
both value.
Okay. Yes. So you get the idea.
That's what an ID is.
So, now let me show you a
passage and we'll do some of
these.
Now the important thing about
passages is that you talk about
the language of the passage as
well as just what's in it.
So, these will be chosen for
the interest of their language,
and you will want to note the
words and talk about why things
are said the way they're said.
Professor Amy
Hungerford: Okay.
So here's one.
Take a moment.
"Now is the time and folks,
I just couldn't.
In silence I turned shoreward
and gravely, dutifully she also
turned and still hell screamed
its counsel and still I could
not make myself drown the poor,
slippery, big-bodied creature."
What is this from?
Uh huh.
Student:
It's from
Lolita.Professor
Amy Hungerford:
Yes,
and what is going on in this
scene?Student:
Humbert is contemplating
killing Charlotte Haze,
Lolita's
mother.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Very good.
Yes.
That's all the context you
would need to identify this
passage.
Now, take a minute and look.
What do you think in the
language of this passage would
be useful to comment on?
What do you notice about it,
about the language?
Yes.Student:
They're using
"folks."Professor Amy
Hungerford:
Yes.Student:
He's addressing the
reader.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Absolutely.
You would have to talk about
that to get full credit for an
answer on this one.
It's an address to the reader.
You'd need to talk about why he
says that, so what would your
account be for why he says
that?Student:
Because he's making a plea
for his innocence,
and he's addressing people in
this formal manner to try and
sort of reach them on a
friendship
level…Professor
Amy Hungerford:
Exactly.
Student:
Yes, and then he just wants
to sort of paint a picture of
his own
morality.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Okay.
Yes. Very good.
That's a very nice way of
putting it, when you say he's
making a plea for his innocence.
That is the whole context of
the novel.
That's what sets up the novel;
that's the frame of the novel.
And so, just by making that
observation, you've done an
important thing for the passage
identifications,
which is that you have drawn
its significance in the context
of the larger novel,
the whole novel.
What else might warrant your
notice here, what other bits of
the language?
Yes.Student:
The attention to
bodies.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Yes.
What about that?Student:
The opposition he sets up
between Charlotte's body and
Lolita's.
Professor Amy
Hungerford: Absolutely,
yes, so that would be perfect,
nice and economical.
What else?
What else do you see there that
you could comment on?
Yes.
Student:
The way that he frames the
explanation like he's a
hero.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Yes.
Yeah, and what would you make
of that in an
answer?Student:
Well, that as much as he's
trying to prove his innocence,
he also really thinks he's
actually doing the right thing
there.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Yes.
Well, we're laughing about it.
You would probably want to note
that it's a comic use of that
literary convention,
and so you could say something
about his deployment of
conventional language,
either for satirical use or for
comedy or to play up the drama
of his self-understanding.
So that would be a nicer point,
a somewhat more subtle
observation, that would set your
exam-grading TF into a state of
happiness, much to be desired.
All right.
Let me see.
I'll show you another one.
Okay.
This one.
Take a minute and read it.
Okay. What's this from?
The Known World.
Okay.
Sometimes we will take out
character names.
I've done this with Oedipa,
in the past,
in Crying of Lot 49,
just because it's so
identified with her that it
seems like too much of a dead
giveaway.
I don't do that very often.
Here, Augustus is an easy
identifier.
What would you want to say
about this passage?
What do you notice about it
that seems worth accounting for?
Uh huh.Student:
You can probably,
with the phrase "I know what I
know,"
connect to the title of The
Known World and make a
comment about how our world is
defined by what we know and the
perception of God's truth and
how that fits
in.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Uh huh.
Absolutely, yeah,
and if you could tie that
notion of God's truth to the
godlike omniscience of the
narrator in The Known World
that would be a great thing
to do,
and that would be a way to tie
your analysis of this passage to
the concerns of the novel as a
whole,
so that would be good to do.
What else do you notice that
you could make use of
thematically or formally here?
Uh huh. Eli.
Privilege Student:
You could connect it to a
vision of morality,
like the way Mildred and Henry
treat their slaves,
related to the way God treats
his children…
Professor Amy
Hungerford: Right.
So both in your example of
Mildred and Henry--not Mildred,
Henry and….Now I've lost
her name.
What is her name,
his wife's name?
Caldonia.
Henry and Caldonia have this
vision of a pure morality that
they could sponsor in their
slave-holding life,
and, similarly,
this is Barnum Kinsey speaking.
You'd want to identify the
speaker here.
Barnum Kinsey dreams of a pure
space in which he could do the
morally right thing,
but as Eli was saying this is a
novel in which no such space or
light is possible,
so you'd want to note that.
That's more a thematic element
of this, but you would want to
note that.
That's really important.
Anything else that we might
want to say?
Yes.Student:
Well, in the language he
repeats "a body could say" and "
a body could stand,"
and it's kind of a way of
preventing literary means of
being excluding the
illiterate.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Uh huh.
Yeah.
I think you can definitely talk
about that.
I think there are a couple of
ways.
One is to associate it with
literacy so that just
being is a way of
testifying,
somehow, that Barnum,
in behaving the way he would
have wanted to behave,
could have done the moral
thing.
But there is a contrast here
between saying it,
being the moral thing,
and his having stood by as a
body in that scene and allowed
Augustus to be sold into
slavery.
So, you could certainly make
hay of that elocution.
And, for any example that uses
dialect in this way,
you do want to interrogate it.
So, don't just say,
"Well, that's just trying to
sound like someone would sound
like in this social situation."
Don't stop there.
Know that the passages will be
chosen so that any irregularity
of language, even if it's for
the purposes of realism and
dialect,
is probably going to be
something you can talk about.
So, just be aware of that and
creative in thinking about what
that variation in language could
mean.
Okay.
Let me show you another.
Okay. What's that from?
Yes.
Student:
On the
Road?Professor Amy
Hungerford:
Yes,
it's from On the
Road, and what would
you want to say about it?
What's important to notice
about the language and what's
important in the thematics of it
and the content of it?
Yes, Sarah?Sarah:
You could talk about the
way that Sal looks at Dean's
language as a way of getting at
a more intimate way of
understanding language…
Professor Amy
Hungerford: Yeah,
absolutely.
So words like that--You'd need
to talk about Dean's language
and, just as Sarah has done,
put it in the context of our
understanding of Dean's language
and its evolution over the
course of the novel,
so that does the work of
getting your interpretation into
the context of an entire
interpretation of the novel.
And there is that sense of
immediacy;
so, making up words in an
attempt to get at an unusual
proximity to experience.
Okay.
What else would you want to
notice?
Well, what's he talking about?
Yes.
Student:
[inaudible]Professor
Amy Hungerford:
Okay.
Yes.
Student:
[inaudible]Professor
Amy Hungerford:
Especially in what?
Sorry.Student:
[inaudible]Professor
Amy Hungerford:
Yeah, absolutely.
The language and the way Dean's
language falls apart over the
course of the novel is one way
that he's trying to get at a
different kind of language.
But music is the figure for
another way, or it's another
figure for that effort to get
beyond the limitations of
language.
And here the way jazz is being
described, its ability to
capture some ineffable thing,
"it," is what you'd want to
highlight.
So, you'd want to connect that
analysis of how jazz is being
described, here,
with the role of jazz in the
novel as a whole,
especially in the novel's
linguistic ambitions,
its literary ambitions.
You might want to notice the
empty space that's highlighted
here.
It's another version of the
vagueness of spirituality in a
couple of our novels on the
syllabus,
but certainly in On the
Road, the vagueness of that
thing that they are looking for.
And also,
you could talk about the
communal dynamics of
meaning-making,
here,
and you could connect that with
how it's important that Sal and
Dean operate in this larger set
of people that sort of ebb and
flow throughout the novel.
This is not the individual
artist sitting alone,
but rather a dream of an
American identity that is
somehow built in a free-thinking
community of people,
or a free-acting community of
people.
So, you get that,
and all of a sudden,
somewhere in the middle of the
chorus, he gets it.
Everybody looks up and knows.
There is a dream there of a
shared meaning-making moment
that everyone will know.
It will be immediately
compelling.
"Rehashes of old blowing."
He's talking about how jazz
musicians are in conversation
with a tradition.
You could use that little piece
and talk about the way that
On the Road is in
conversation with other literary
traditions,
how it imagines itself as a
revision of modernism.
We had a wonderful paper that I
think some of you saw as a
sample about the relationship
between Hemingway and Kerouac in
this novel.
I didn't lecture on this,
but if any of you saw that
paper, that's an example of what
you might want to say about the
relationship between tradition
and innovation,
which is thematized here in
jazz, but it's acted out in the
novel as well.
Okay.
Do you get the idea of how
these work?
Okay.
So this is what I'm looking for
in the passages.
Now, in the essays,
usually, we have extremely
broad questions,
some of which are more
theoretical than others.
Some are more thematic.
We had one I'll show you in a
minute about work that looks
quite different from this one,
but here is the question:
"It is often said that many of
the humanistic disciplines of
the second half of the twentieth
century are marked by their
interest in language itself.
In other words,
language becomes not just a
medium but a problem.
To what extent are the problems
of language foregrounded in the
novels of this period?
What are the consequences of
this turn for the writing of
fiction?
How does such a foregrounding
affect the traditional terms of
the novel, concerns of the
novel,
the creation of character,
the relationship between style
and content, problems of
verisimilitude,
etc.?"Now,
you would have to choose one of
those groups,
and then within one of those
groups of novels you would need
to choose three of the four to
talk about.
So, the essay will be bringing
together three novels around one
of these questions.
The reason I group them this
way is because some of the
novels on the syllabus you could
put together and have a very
partial account of what fiction
in this period looks like.
So, say your novels were Barth,
Pynchon and Foer.
All of them have very similar
formal ambitions.
Okay.
I would not make it possible
for you to do that.
So, I'm looking for you to be
able to take texts that seem
unlike in their concerns and in
their formal elements and put
them into conversation with each
other around a particular
question.
Okay.
Similarly, I would not ask you
to do Woman Warrior,
Bluest Eye, and Known
World.
I wouldn't ask you to do
probably Woman Warrior,
Bluest Eye, and Human
Stain, either.
It's all too much about
identity in somewhat similar
terms, so I wouldn't ask you
those novels together.
So, you can see that I mix them
up.
Don't forget Black Boy.
That will be on the exam.
If you joined the course in the
middle of reading week--in the
middle of shopping period--you
might want to go back and fill
that into your reading,
if you haven't read that.
Let's see.
Questions about the essay
questions.
I highly, highly recommend that
you take the time to outline.
If you're not used to taking
essay exams, or even if you are,
it is a huge help.
It's actually a time saver.
It ensures that you don't get
bogged down in sentence
constructions.
When we grade these,
typically what we do is make
checks in the margin every time
you make a specific point and
use a specific citation of a
specific part of a novel.
So, you can't quote 'cause you
don't have the books in front of
us, in front of you,
although if you do want to use
passages that are on the exam
you can quote from those.
You can use parts of the exam
for quotation in the essay,
but you do need to say,
"When Morrison starts each
chapter of The Bluest Eye
with that quotation from the
primer,
she is highlighting how
learning language is also
learning a kind of racial
prejudice and it's a kind of
racial prejudice rooted in
aesthetic appreciation.
She highlights the colors that
appear in the primer and
prettiness of Jane's dresses."
Okay.
I didn't quote anything from
The Bluest Eye,
but I'm pointing to it in
such a way that that would have
several checks in the column in
the margin,
and basically what we do is we
rack it up and we see whether
for each novel you've made a
number of specific points that
add up to an argument.
Now, in this essay this is
the only place where we really
don't want you simply coughing
up lecture or something that
you've discussed in section.
This is, like the papers,
something of an opportunity to
draw things together in an
original way.
There are lots of threads that
connect the novels in the
syllabus.
If you've been attending the
lectures, you will already have
lots of those in your notes,
so you can draw from that,
but you should be thinking
about it on your own.
For the passages,
when you start to make claims
about why the passage is
important,
in the context of the novel as
a whole, you may find yourself
using arguments that were made
in lecture or in section,
and that's fine.
So, it gives you the larger
context in which you can show us
that you're able to look at the
specific words on the page and
tell us something about them.
That's the skill we're testing
in the passages.
Here, it's more your synthetic
knowledge and your way of
bringing things together.
So in studying for the exam
portion, as I say,
read over the paper topics and
make little lists for yourself
of kinds of evidence that you
would point to,
maybe four or five bits of
evidence for each novel,
or for a number of novels,
that might help you answer a
question like that on the exam.
Or, sit and think;
read a question and think to
your mind, "okay,
which scenes would I note;
which scenes would I want to
talk about?"
That's a good exercise for
studying.
Any questions about this?
Okay.
Let me show you one more.
So, that's a very,
sort of, literary kind of
version of the exam question.
Let me show you something of a
more, perhaps a cultural studies
version.
Here's one about work.
The quotation is from Plot
Against America,
Philip Roth's recent novel,
which is what I taught of his
last year, so that obviously
would not occur on our exam.
""The men worked fifty,
sixty, even seventy or more
hours a week.
The women worked all the time
with little assistance from
labor-saving devices."
Discuss the status of work in
the post-1945 American novel.
Who works and who doesn't?
How is work represented?
What kinds of work are
valorized?
What kinds are vilified?
What is the place of labor in
these novels' vision of
America?"
So, that's a more thematic
question, but in all of these we
really want you to be noting how
narratives are put together,
how language is used,
what choices the novel made in
privileging either description
of character and development of
character,
development of setting,
creativity in voices and tones.
So, all those formal things
that have to do with language
choices would still be relevant.
Here you might want to talk
about the work of the writer as
that novel imagines it.
We've talked about that over,
on and off over the course of
the term.
What is the literary project?
What does the literary project
have to do with other kinds of
work?
So, generally,
partly because this course is
cross-listed in American
Studies,
I like to have something of a
balance between those very
literary formal questions like
that first one I showed you and
this one,
which is a little bit more
about a vision of America.
Okay.
Any questions?
You probably have your ways
of studying by now.
Even freshmen have been here
for a year.
Let me just say a couple things
about the process of studying
and of taking exams that maybe
will be helpful to you.
My ideal way of studying for an
exam is to use sleep
strategically.
Sleep can do amazing things for
the consolidation of knowledge
in your brain.
Maybe some of you have
discovered this already.
discovered its negative,
what it does not do for you
when you do not sleep.
If you can arrange it so that
you spend time so you get all
your reading done,
read over all your notes,
then sit down with those paper
topics, and while you're sitting
with the paper topics,
that's when you move from going
from the passive mode to the
active mode.
So, you review all your notes,
sit down with the paper topics.
In that active mode,
do what I was suggesting.
Think of scenes that pertain to
those topics for a number of the
novels, for each one.
Just work through that for
awhile, until you can't do it
anymore, and then go to sleep
right away.
Do not check your e-mail.
Do not browse the web.
Do not shoot the breeze with
your roommate.
[laughs] Just go to bed.
There is a lot of research
that's been done about the
effect of doing this without
distracting yourself.
You still get a benefit if you
distract yourself and then go to
bed.
You still retain more of the
knowledge the next morning,
but it's even better if you do
it without distracting yourself.
So, take it to bed with you,
so you can sink right into bed,
into sleep, later.
Even if you can only nap even
for twenty minutes or half an
hour, it still has an effect.
So, say you have to study for
this exam during one half of the
day, and then you have to go and
take another exam during the
second half of the day.
Take a nap in between.
It's probably worth the half
hour you don't spend thinking
about more paper topics,
or reading your notes over
again, or looking at the novels
to do that.
It's probably worth it.
Okay.
So that's my first tip:
Use sleep strategically.
My second reflection on
exam taking is that--you may
dismiss this out of hand,
given the profession that I
then took up--but I actually
used to like taking exams.
And the reason was that,
once you went through that work
of reading things over,
processing it,
after you took the exam itself,
I always felt that the
knowledge of a course was really
my own then.
It came together in a way that
was much more solid for me than
before I took the exam.
So, right now the themes of the
course might just be a
collection of memories,
or partial memories,
and in your notes,
and sort of chaotic.
But once you study for the
exam, and you get some distance
from it--with sleep--and you
actually write the exam,
that knowledge is really your
own.
So, I would encourage you to
see exam period,
not just in this class but in
all your classes,
as a real time,
an important time,
of consolidation.
You worked very hard during the
term in all your classes,
I hope, and whatever you did
can really become yours in a new
way during this time.
So use it well.
And, I hope that you'll-in some
way, some part of you--will
enjoy that process of really
coming to own that knowledge.
Okay.
Any questions about the exam?
Any questions about anything in
the course?
Eli.Student:
I wanted to ask why "1945"
is particularly
important.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Why postwar?
Well, in America that marks two
things for me.
One is the rise of the mass
market and that
changes…Well,
actually I would say three
things.
The rise of the mass market
changes the relationship between
readership and the literature
that's out there.
So, it used to be that "high
literature" was not published in
paperback, but the rise of the
mass-market paperback meant that
suddenly books that would never
be accessible to a sort of
average middle-class or
working-class person suddenly
became so.
So, it's a huge watershed in
the demographics of readership.
So, that's one reason.
A second reason is related
to this, and that's that
hundreds of thousands of men
came back and went to college on
the GI Bill who had never been
to college before.
Nobody in their families had
ever been to college before.
This also changed the
readership dramatically.
It was a time of an enormous
boom in college enrollments,
and part of that was a huge
boom in English enrollments.
Literature was a way for people
who had never been to college
before to feel that they were
entering in to the upper middle
class because it was a kind of
pursuit that was marked by its
bourgeois prestige,
or its prestige marked you as
bourgeois.
So, for people interested in
raising their class status,
and that was lots of people,
coming into the educational
system, higher education,
for the first time,
literature was very important.
There is a whole story about
why literature is no longer that
class-marking enterprise that it
was at mid century that has to
do with the rise of writing,
the competence in writing being
more important than the
competence in literary tradition
to mark you as an educated
person.
So, that's an interesting story
in itself, but in general 1945
is the beginning of that.
The third thing is that,
by 1945, the innovations of
modernism are really very well
established.
The big careers of early
century literary enterprise are
totally established,
and they have been assumed
almost fully into the
institution of the university
through the New Criticism.
The New Criticism was that
method of reading literature
that was determining how people
were reading in classrooms,
how all those new college
students were reading in
classrooms.
That set the agenda for what
would come next,
so in that context someone like
John Barth,
trained intensively in the New
Criticism, had to decide what he
was going to do as a literarily
ambitious writer to innovate.
So, it was a question of,
how could literature carry on
and do something new?
And there are lots of different
answers to that.
And another answer to it,
that is partly the result of
the GI Bill explosion of
education,
that's the changing demographic
of who gets to read and who gets
to write.
So, women, people of color,
begin to change the agendas of
modernism simply by getting that
education and entering into the
academy.
So, Toni Morrison is a great
example of that.
So is Maxine Hong Kingston.
There was this sense that
modernism had not even begun to
touch on the experience of vast
swaths of society,
and writers like Morrison and
Kingston were very busy wanting
to rectify that.
So, it marks a change that's
beyond just a change in
readership.
The demographic change in
readership and in education
really begins to change the
agenda of literature.
So, that's why '45 is my marker.
It's a crude one,
like all these things.
You can't say,
"Well, why not 1942?"
It doesn't quite work that
specifically.
Okay.
Other questions about the
course, about terms,
about books.
Yes.
Student:
Of the novels you read,
what are your favorite ones?
I know you have them,
too.Professor Amy
Hungerford: You do,
do you?
Gosh.
That's really,
really hard.
I do love The Known World.
I really admire it.
I think it's genuinely doing
something new,
and that's hard to do right
now;
so I love it,
and I loved it as a reading
experience, even when I first
read it.
It really captured my
imagination.
I have always loved and hated
Blood Meridian.
I love and hate Cormac
McCarthy.
I've spent a lot of time
thinking about him,
writing about him,
reading his work,
and while I am really in awe of
his ability especially to use
the far reaches of our
vocabulary in English.
Talk about someone who really
makes room in the language.
He can really do that.
If you read the first few pages
of one of his earlier novels,
Suttree, you get a
fantastic image of this.
It's a very Joycean novel,
that one.
The vocabulary-- You just have
to look up every third word.
It's really incredible.And
I'm really interested in the way
he is focused on craft,
both as a writer,
but all kinds of crafts.
He has this play called The
Last Stonemason.
I think it's called The
Last Stonemason or just
The Stonemason.
He's interested in these
old arts, physical arts like
forging.
There's a great chapter on
smithing in a novel called
The Child of God where
the language of the smithy is
folded into this meditation on
aesthetics,
talks about what color the fire
and the metal should be at every
moment of reforging an ax
handle.
Of course, in true McCarthy
style, the ax handle will then
be used to chop up dead bodies
and skin people,
so that's very McCarthyesque
too.
But at the same time I just
find him frustratingly empty.
The Road I adored.
It was a terrifying read.
I had insomnia one night,
and I started to read it at
about 1:30 in the morning,
and I finished it about 5:30
and I was terrified.
Have I told you about The
Road, what it's about?
It takes place ten years into a
nuclear winter,
and it's about a father and son
making their way down from
Appalachia to the Gulf Coast,
for no apparent reason except
that the father seems to think
that somehow they'll be able to
survive better once they get to
the coast.
Meanwhile, in this world,
there are all these
cannibalistic gangs that have
started.
Women are used to produce
babies that they then eat.
It's really completely bleak
and terrifying and the
relationship between the father
and the son is extremely
touching,
and I have a little boy who is
about the same age and oh,
my God, I was just--it was
really terrifying to read this
all alone in the middle of the
night.
I sort of got in bed with my
son later and just kind of
cuddled with him to remember
that he was still alive.But,
at the end, there is this sense
of the boy carrying the light.
The father says,
"We're carrying the light.
We're the good guys."
And the son sort of repeats
that.
By the end--and I won't tell
you what happens 'cause you
should read it--but there is
this affirmation of that light,
but what the light is,
who knows?
There is sort of a Promethean
narrative there.
There is also a messianic
I think, personally,
my own meaning of it,
is that it's McCarthy
meditating on the end of his own
life.
McCarthy is a very old man with
a very young son,
and I think he was thinking
about his own death.
And the fate of the father in
that novel, I think,
is very much about McCarthy's
sense of himself.
So yeah, McCarthy is a tough
one.
Marilynne Robinson I like a
lot also.
I like the beauty of her prose.
That biblical cadence that she
and McCarthy both have I really
like.
I love the outdoor imagery,
the nature imagery,
of that novel.
And I love Roth for my own
obscure and perverse reasons.
Yeah.
So I sort of have my favorites,
but I like them--I,
really, there are things that I
like about all of them.
An interesting story about
liking novels:
I hated Salinger.
I really hated Salinger,
because I found him so
pretentious and affected.
I just hated that tone of
voice, until I was working on
this book on religion and I read
Franny and Zooey.
And here you can tell most
of my great thought happens in
the middle of the night.
So, I had been thinking about
Franny and Zooey,
and I suddenly woke up in
the middle of the night
thinking,
"I know what style is for in
Franny and Zooey!"
So, I got up and I wrote it
down,
and that lecture that I gave on
Franny and Zooey is part
of my new book.
And when the book was reviewed
for presses, a part of it,
one of my readers said it was
the best reading he had ever
seen of contemporary fiction.
And it made me love Franny
and Zooey 'cause suddenly I
had something to think about
other than well,
this is so pretentious.
I had a reason why that tone
and that style was there.
So, thinking about books can
really change your sense of
whether you like them or not in
a self--I know--in a
self-serving way.
Now who's pretentious?
Okay.
Other questions.
Oh, yes.
Student:
I really love Toni
Morrison's novel Beloved,
and I was talking to my
roommate about it,
wondering why it isn't on the
syllabus.
I know it's taught in American
literature courses,
but he thought it might be
like,
academic snobbery,
because it's popular,
and Oprah Winfrey talks about
it…Professor Amy
Hungerford: Oh,
no, not at all.
I used to teach
Beloved, and I
stopped because of that,
because we put it on the 127
syllabus, partly.
And that wasn't here when I
first started teaching;
so, the first time I offered
this lecture course,
127 didn't exist.
And then we put it in place in
the department,
and because it was on that
syllabus, I held off.
I still think Beloved is
an amazing novel.
I also have the length problem
in that part of the period.
I'm sure you didn't notice that
the novels are long in that part
of the syllabus.
Beloved is another
really huge novel,
so that it's a problem.
So, I decided instead of
putting it on,
to rely on the fact that most
people would either have read it
in high school,
or at least a majority would
have read it in high school,
or in 127, and that I could
count on that knowledge,
at least in a contextual sense.
But no, it has nothing to do
with academic snobbery.
Now, I used to get pissed off
because when it was on the
syllabus I would always get,
certain evaluations would come
in and say, "I don't know why we
read Beloved.
It's so overrated."
That was the snobbery,
and that made me upset 'cause I
thought well,
that's just a failure of
openness as a reader,
not to think about why it was
so powerful, even if you don't
like it yourself.
But, your answer was right.
It's simply because it's taught
a lot elsewhere,
and then those other practical
reasons of length.
What else?
Uh huh.Student:
Are there authors that you
would have included,
if it were a longer
semester.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Oh.
Well, I'm sure, yeah.
So, let's see.
What else would I put on there?
Well, let me think.
Louise Erdrich is interesting
to me.
There is a long novel of hers
called The Last Report on the
Miracles at Little No Horse,
which I think is an
imaginative conceit.
It is really fascinating.
The premise of the novel is,
it's this young woman who is a
wonderfully gifted pianist who
goes--I can't remember where
she's heading.
It's been now a long time since
I read the novel.
She's traveling,
and she gets washed away in a
flood, a freak flood of a river.
This is out West.
And, when she finally surfaces,
she crawls up on the bank,
and she finds the body of a
young priest who was on his way
to be the priest at a mission on
a reservation,
on an Indian reservation,
I think, in the Dakotas.
So, she cuts off her hair,
and she puts on the priest's
robes, and she pretends to be
that priest.
And she becomes--she
cross-dresses and is the priest
at the reservation for her
entire life.
And I just think it's a
fascinating premise for a novel,
and it's very well done and her
language is quite wonderful.
Again, I am ambivalent about
it, because I find the ending
facile.
It finally resolves all the
problems that this situation
produces in a way that I don't
find complex enough,
or challenging enough.
It's just too easy to make it
all come together the way she
does.
So, that's one.
Let me think.
There are many,
many other novels.
I'm perpetually torn whether to
put The Road on,
or Blood Meridian,
or some other McCarthy
novel.
I've taught at least four
different Roth novels spanning
the period from 1960 to the
present.
Other writers…
Now, I don't know why I'm
blanking, now that I think about
this.
Who else would I like to put on
there?
Oh, Eggers.
Now I "fess up."
I really would have loved to do
What is the What as our
last novel.
Now, Eggers started out
immature, in the same way that,
I think, Jonathan Safran Foer
is.
But he grew up,
and it's a beautiful thing.
So, A Heartbreaking Work of
Staggering Genius has a lot
of that sort of kind of
clichéd,
postmodern trickery in it,
but by the time he gets to
What is the What,
that novel is like
nothing else.
There is no equivalent of that
novel, to my knowledge,
anywhere in our tradition.
It's just an astonishing
inhabitation of another person's
life, but in real time.
I was able to have dinner with
him and some other people when
he came as the Schlesinger
writer a few years ago,
and I said, "Did you find it
confining to give yourself over
in that creative way to this
other person's story?"
And he said, "Yeah.
It was terrible.
I'd be writing 'The truck went
down the road.'"
He'd have to call Valentino and
say, "Valentino,
that truck--was the road
gravel, or was it paved?
And was it dusty?
Was there stuff kicking up,
or was it just flat?"
It was just amazing,
the degree to which he put his
writing pen at the service of
another person and their story.
It's really remarkable,
so, given that extremely
confining setup,
he makes that novel truly
literary, in my mind.
It has a real form,
it has a very lively voice,
and it's extremely powerful and
affecting.
So, that's something I would
love to have,
but again it's a huge novel,
so this is the problem.
It's so long.
I think I just need two
semesters.
I think that would be better.
Yes.
Student:
What about Jonathan Safran
Foer's latest
book?Professor Amy
Hungerford: I haven't read
it yet,
but I have to say the reviews
that I hear about it--so,
was it Extremely Loud and
Incredibly Close?--the
structure of the plot makes me
doubt,
a little bit,
because it's just another hunt.
So, it's this nine-year-old boy
who loses his father on 9/11,
and he finds in his father's
effects a key that's marked
"Black," I think.
It has a little label on it,
and so he goes around in New
York City finding everyone by
the name of Black that he can
find.
So, it has this structure
that's so similar to
Everything is Illuminated.
That hunt structure just
made me think,
I wonder whether this is just a
one-trick writer,
that he has this idea and this
is what it's always going to be?
That doesn't necessarily mean
that someone is not a great
writer.
Roth is kind of a one-trick
pony, in this way,
too.
He has his own repetitions from
novel to novel.
Most writers I know do,
but that seemed a little
too--It was a little too close
for me, so I don't know.
I have to find time to read it.
Denis Johnson:
I did actually-- I was very
interested in having Jesus'
Son as the last novel,
too.
I'm going to write a review for
the Yale Review on Denis
Johnson's work by the end of
July, so by then I'll know what
I think about him,
too.
Other questions?
Or shall I let you go?
Any other questions?
Okay.
So I will see you at the exam,
and I think some sections are
having review sessions,
so check with your TF.